christophe porzingis very very unique
talent please above the rim and also
plays behind the arc I've been talking
to a lot of GM's they all love Chris
they think he's a top five talent and
it's draft there's a little bit of a
risk attached to him but the upside is
worth it
I realize I can play in the NBA one day
when I was 18 after European
Championship a lot of people started to
be interested in this young guy from
Latvia this skinny white dude you don't
find many guys who are 7 feet maybe 7
foot one who are just as skilled at it
the first thing that sticks out is that
jump shot I mean this mechanics has
confidence when you shoot it it's
effortless get the feeling that every
jumper is going to fall I'm all
versatile forward I can't stretch the
floor I can play on the rim above the
rim I'm a good rebounder and when I get
stronger probably I'm going to be able
to play multiple positions that
combination of shot blocking and
three-point shooting it's very very hard
to find in the NBA today there are
really only a handful a guide to do it
that's why I think he's so coveted right
now I played two and a half years and
professionally I've been around
professionals a long time Spanish league
is very competitive so there's a lot of
competition over in Europe I mean he's
playing against pros he's playing
against grown men that's obviously a big
difference you know from what most of
these college guys see on a weekly basis
that's the biggest transition a lot of
college kids mid-drive we have to make
it plain against men
that Christophe has already been doing
that's going to make things easier for
him for sure
two of the players that I admire are
Dirk Nowitzki and Pau Gasol I follow kg
I've seen a lot of his highlights I've
studied his game now
I love how Anthony Davis plays I try to
simulate my game to theirs
what's going to be a few years before
porzingis is really an impact player 220
pounds he just doesn't have the bulk
right now to play down low and I'm not
sure he's skilled enough with his handle
to be a forward out on the perimeter
just yet there's plenty potential award
but also some risk attached to I think a
lot of NBA GM's are worried about
Europeans that they don't love the game
as as the Americans do I have that in me
I love the game of student of the game
so we'll see what happens on got it